I've also gotten to write to great  numbers with Will Ferrell and Jack Black  the first one was that there was actual  lyrics to the get off the stage music  and that was pretty funny and then last  year we did with the addition of john c  reilly a song about what it's like to be  a comedian at the oscars and ever  getting you do and those were really fun  to work on because obviously those guys  are fun to work with I feel cool that  they liked me and that I'm getting to  write once again to be able to write  words it's it's like this most  egotistical thing on earth to write  words for other people to say it's like  I feel like it's just a strange feeling  and when you have like Will Ferrell and  Jack Black saying them it's just amazing